hello everybody and welcome to the
seventh Python programming with flask
and general web development tutorial
video in this video we're going to be
talking about the dashboard which is
basically this right here so this is the
crux of this website this is where all
the logic is and this is the main
quote/unquote web app for my website so
let's get started so first of all what
we need is we we need to have our header
file which we've already created the
header file we've just done nothing with
it and then we'll have dashboard
actually I want to say inherit from it
but it's going to extend using flask
lingo the header file so first let's
make this header so what we need to do
is we're going to take main HTML and I'm
going to just go ahead and highlight all
copy come over to dashboard or no I'm
sorry
header in haste now what we're going to
do is within our body uh we're going to
will keep this div here and let's get
rid of because again this is our header
so what we want to do is we're going to
keep that div we'll delete every we'll
delete the video within it will keep the
scripts because those are going to be
necessary and then what we're going to
do is height 100% and instead of just a
height we're going to say
min height 100% so it can be taller if
it needs to be and then we're also going
to we'll convert this to a container
fluid and now what we're going to do is
first of all we can do we're going to
add some logic here so we've got a block
body and then we're going to do
basically some more logic and then we
have end block now what this is is this
is flask code and this is for when we do
an extension which we're about to do for
dashboard so I'll show you a little bit
more about that
moment now the only other thing I want
to go ahead and have us add real quick
is this border row so right now um you
can see that let's just save this real
quick and now we're just going to let's
just add the border oh I lost pointed
out in a moment so it's going to be a
div class vehicles and its border dash
row and then what's style equals width :
100% and then we're going to add a bit
of a margin so margin - bottom : 15
pixels and that's it and then we'll go
ahead and close off that div so this is
our header file and now we can come over
to our dashboard and we're not going to
add too much right now to this dashboard
but for now this is going to extend or
or what I would want to call inherit
from the header but it's going to extend
it and so to extend
we're going to use some logic here and
it's going to be extends and then you
put in quotes what it extends this one
extends header HTML and again extends is
going to search for templates within the
templates directory so if it's extending
a template that say in templates a
footer let's say you would add the
footer in here so you put our slash okay
so just keep that in mind and I'm going
to go and delete footers we're not
actually going to use that but it's
extending header HTML and then we're
going to use the same uh text here so
block body and block we're going to do
again here block body and basically
block body is going to go all the way to
the very end where you would have end
block so you've got block body and then
and block oops and block and then here
we could just have maybe some quick
paragraph tags and say hello
okay let's knocked over my water save
that
that's dashboard it's extending hetero
HTML or a header HTML was a copy and
paste of our other page there so
everything should be fine up to this
point
let's check refresh good so we can see
that our um the init dot pi that we have
is where are you here you are right here
it is dashboard and it returns the
template dashboard at HTML which is this
this is all that template is but it has
successfully extended this template
entering basically all of the content on
dashboard right here between the block
body and it's enforcing this hundred
percent although you don't really see
it's we don't have a footer at the
moment but it's there uh one more thing
is see the border row for whatever
reason appears to not be appearing
what are you as weird I thought that was
all we needed for a border uh like a
line in the border what am I missing let
me go let's go back here and because we
want that I do want that border roof I
see you've got dashboard we'll keep
scrolling down to do ok it would be now
would it
wouldn't it not be this right here let's
let's just copy this from the website
and we will come over here paste save
that that is header fresh ah it's odd I
would like to know what the dealio is
there
um okay well I'll look into that and see
what the heck is happening here I don't
really know why that would happen that's
very frustrating
anyways um I'd like to have it but we'll
just ignore that for now it's not
essential and I'm tired of HTML at this
point and so we're going to continue
along so Abra dashboard okay cool so now
what do we want to do well now at this
point we want to have uh we know we have
all this content that we want of course
now I've got a return you know HTML
whatever so we're going to go to get
bootstrap and we are looking for those
tabs I'm hoping I can just scroll
through and see them I'm pretty sure
they're in let's do a nav Dallas over
here nav - tabs okay not those tabs is
not what we want
maybe it's the yeah these are the tabs
that we want okay so food-truck fixie a
raw denim you probably it's interesting
random text they have here so this is
this toggle bolt tabs tab dot j s that
which means we'll have to probably
include that spinner wants that wrote it
and so we have this this is our tab
content let's just copy and paste this
markup that they have here so copy we'll
come over here we come to our dashboard
and we'll just paste in those tabs that
they've given to us thank you thank you
let's see if they work okay the tabs at
least work I don't see the fade effect
but it looks like I see it right down
here so let me just copy and paste that
again so the fades will come back over
here is right under it so now in the tab
content you just add fade and you have
an active tab which is you know you're
starting tab so come back over here and
that was all the divs so we'll just do
this spoon say that refresh I assumed it
would fade but it is just we've got no
content and
don't see how other it is right here so
we do have our dot dot to put it this
over and I think what's happening is
that's because of our Center do we have
a set yeah so we've got this align
Center nonsense uh let's get rid of that
we don't need to be centering any
alignment and then I wonder if that's
what was causing our prom no because we
were right above that miracle it's
refreshes one last time there we go at
least this stuff is over here now uh min
height and let's say let's see if we can
get away with wit 80% for now okay so
we'll come back to that as well I hate
dealing with CSS and stuff so anyway um
so at least we have the tabs here we see
that it is fading these dots for us so
now we want to talk about how do we
actually add content to these tabs so
right now they say home
profile messages settings let's let's
change those so we'll come save header
it will just leave header alone for a
while refresh this okay still working so
now we come over here and so the way
this works is you've got the H ref which
is pound home and then you've got home
here and then this is just the name that
goes on the tab but then you'll want to
change home and home here to be
identical to basically home wherever
this ID is so instead of home well let's
call this basics and then we'll
literally just call these basics as well
the little hash tags and then the Aria
controls basics basics and then a basic
stuff here okay we've got basics let's
do a web dev so we'll call that W dev
paste paste and will say web dev and
let's just get rid of settings I don't
feel like doing an or a fourth one and
then finally
we'll do data analysis and we'll call it
dan data analysis paste paste paste and
then data analysis
okay so save hopefully those @ signs
don't screw us over nope okay
so now you can see that okay we've got
these tabs got custom content in the
tabs awesome now what we want to do is
actually work on our content management
system and that's going to be how do we
actually populate these tabs with
content and then not only that but how
do we maybe manipulated over time so of
course we could come in and we could say
that the basics tab first let's delete
this we're going to make some space here
because each tab is going to contain
some stuff so now of course we could
come in and we could add some tags here
for unordered list and then we could add
you know list
oops not lie list item slash list item
and then we could have copy that
kay paste part one part two and part
three and we could really just you know
handwrite all of this stuff that's
within here we can make them links into
the tutorial but the problem is for
let's say in a week you decide you want
to add more stuff you want to take away
maybe you want to reorganize this whole
table so to an extent you you want to
have some sort of content management
system in the backend under the
background that kind of drives what
shows here plus we are using Python the
whole point of using Python is to use
logic where we can to generate the HTML
so that's what we're going to talk about
the next video is how we're going to
build a content management system to
take say a list of topics some URLs
organize them for us and link to the
pages in a very custom manner so that's
what we'll be talking about in the next
video if you do have any questions or
comments up to this point feel free to
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching things for all the
support and subscriptions until the next
video